hello i'm matthias from data tab
this video is about the
standard deviation
after this video you know what the
standard deviation is how you
calculate it is why there are two
different forms and what the
difference was now is and
let's go what is the standard deviation
standard deviation is a measure of
how much your data scatters around
the mean so
standard deviation has something
to do with the variability of your data
let's keep a simple example in mind that standard deviation tells you
how much
data scatters around the mean let's
say  what is the height of a small group of
people measured the
standard deviation tells us how much
our data scatters around the mean
so we first have to
calculate the mean you can get the mean
simply by adding up the
sizes of the individual people
and dividing them by the number  of the people
partly
say  we get an average value of
155 cm so on average these
six people are one meter 55 tall now
we want to know how much each
person deviates from the average value
so we look at the first person
who knows 18 cm from the average value and the
second person  extends 8 cm from the
mean the third person
15cm defined 8 cm the fifth nine
centimeters and finally the sixth
person deviates 6 cm from the mean
now it is not interested in the
deviation of each individual person
from the mean but you want to
know how much the people  on
average, the mean value
deviate how much do these six people
range on average from the
mean
value that said the standard deviation in this case there is an
average deviation from the
mean value of 12.06 centimeters
and now of course the
question arises and how do I calculate that
standard deviation  you can use this
formula to calculate that widmer is  The
standard
deviation is the number of people, the height of the individual people and nothing is the mean of all people. So the standard deviation is the root of the sum of the quartered deviations divided by the number of hours
. For our example,
this means that we have the height of the
first person  - calculate the average
and quarter the sizes of the second
person - vary the average and the thanks
and so on and so forth until
we have reached the last person
we divide this by the number
of
people, i.e. six, and take the result as a root  is then
12.06 centimetres, so each individual
person has a certain deviation from the mean value,
but on average, the
six people were 12.06 cm
from the mean value
I would actually just
add up all the deviations and major  ch
share the number of participants just like you
calculate the averages or
roads are absolutely right there are
different averages in the case of the
standard deviation really that all
ethical means used but the
quadratic with who the arithmetic
mean would be used would
come out zero every time so far so  well now there
is one more thing to note
namely there are two slightly
different forms for the
standard deviation the difference
between the equation is that once
divided by n and once divided by
a - 1 but why that why there are
two different
forms usually  if you
want to know the standard deviation of the population, for example you want to know
what is the standard deviation of
the height of all german professional
football players if you now had the height of all
german professional football
players you would use this
equation with 1 divided by m
usually is  e  But it's not
possible to survey the entire population, so
you take a sample and want
to use this sample to
estimate the standard deviation of the population. In that case, you use this
woman with 1 through - 1,
so whenever all the data hass and calculate the
standard billing for exactly this
data  you want to use 1 through
you only have a sample you want
to estimate the standard
deviation you use one through a - 1 if
you have created a questionnaire and have
not surveyed the entire population with one
questionnaire,
you always use the forms on the right-hand
side just as if  you did a clinical
study
you also use the
shapes on the right to infer
the population then we get to the next point what is the difference between the variance and the standard deviation
how do you now the
standard deviation is the average
distance from the m  mean value the variance,
on the other hand, is the quartered
average distance from the
mean value, so we have one and the
same form, with the
standard deviation still being
preferred, with the variance not put the other way around
, the variant criticized
standard deviation and the
standard deviation is the root of the
variance resulting from this squaring
However, a key figure that is difficult to
interpret in the case of the
variant, since the unit used to
calculate it does not match the
original data. For this
reason, it is advisable to
always use the
standard deviation to describe a sample, since
the interpretation is easier here.
The standard deviation is always  in
the same unit as the initial data in
our example, i.e. in centimeters and
finally two tips for you
firstly
want to calculate the standard deviation you can
easily hike with the app makes
visitors easy to copy day.de
your deeds the table and select the
variables house that you want to calculate
then you get the
standard deviation
output in an uncomplicated way and the second is our
brand new statistics book statistics made
easy with the e-book it understands the
basics of statistics with many graphics and simple texts
if you
like look  just look at the
link you will find in the video
description i hope you like the video
see you
next time bye